championship
[Music]
so we're excited a championship for
unlv's dance team called the rebel Girls
and Company taking home first place in
two categories at a competition over the
weekend in Orlando
take a look
[Music]
oh I'm just in awe it's so cool to watch
the rebels girls company says his
performance gave them a final score of
99.1 the highest d1a hip-hop score in
the program's history they won Top spots
in the D1 game day and Hip-Hop
categories you don't have eight now
five-time Champs in both categories so a
huge shout out to the dance squad there
at UNLV you can hear the crowd in the uh
in the theater they're going nuts too
it's just so fun to watch when you go to
those competitions you know it's your
it's your competition who's watching you
too as well as parents and stuff so to
hear them cheering means they're
cheering for each other and I love that
I wonder how long it took to get that
Precision down that was that had to be
um there's a lot of rehearsals a lot of
rehearsal games they have a basketball
team too
yeah that's right there you go they're
both doing all right guys and girls